Hey guys. How's it going? It's Justine. And today
we are doing a what's on my iPhone
X video these videos are always so highly requested and so crazy because a lot of the times
I start completely fresh when I get a new phone and the iPhone X is no exception
I also started fresh from when I got the iPhone 8
And I thought for sure that I was gonna just port everything over to the new one and I decided no
I'm gonna start fresh on my iPhone X
Let's do this, and it usually takes me a good two weeks
Which it's been a little bit over two weeks now that have had the iPhone X to really get back into the flow
Figure out what apps I need and you definitely figure out very very quickly what apps you cannot live without when you don't have any
Apps at all so starting on my first page these are
Not quite in any particular order, like I used to have, let's see, I used to have this over here
I like to have my maps
I don't really use my phone that often, but I'll put that one back over there
So things aren't exactly the way that I used to have them, but this is sort of my work in progress
This is what I cannot live without basically. I should title it that. What apps can I not live without No clickbait?
Hello only clickbait, if it's not true to starting off here from the top. I've got my calendar
I've got my Apple maps and Google Maps, and I tend to only use Apple maps when I'm in the car
And I have it connected to car play because it integrates very well with my car then if I'm wearing my watch it alerts me
When I need to turn so a lot of times they'll opt to use that when I'm driving as opposed to Google Maps
But I do feel like if I need to get somewhere and I want to make sure that there's a traffic
Or this or that I do feel like Google is much more reliable still to this day
But Apple Maps integrates with my car and my body so it's it's a tough choice anyway moving on o'clock
We've got the phone. We've got the Notes app which I use a lot
I use it for everything I use it for making lists things that I need to buy video ideas
It's probably my number one most used app next to messages next is the App Store then Instagram Twitter snapchat
HQ trivia if you guys haven't been playing HP trivia it is the most fun game I've been talking about a non-stop
It's not sponsored. This is just honest-to-goodness excitement for a fun game basically twice a day
there is live trivia you play you can win real money if you'd like and you have it already sign up using my
Little code right there so that I can get some free lives. Yes. I need the lives then if you miss a question
It's almost like you didn't actually miss it because they gave you a life, but you can only use one life per game
Ah the struggle. I am so bad at trivia
It's unbelievable next up we have Facebook and then Amazon and then Amazon Prime now
Which allows you to get deliveries almost within an hour or two Apple TV remote YouTube and then YouTube studio
Which is a studio app for creators?
It basically lets you have more features
You can edit thumbnails you can do stuff that creators need to to who there's more in-depth analytics you get the point settings
Starbucks very important right next to post mates, and if I didn't have Cole's mates
I probably would be very hungry all the time
Or I would have to learn to cook and clearly we know how cooking goes for me and down the bottom
I have kind of like my most used things which no matter what page. I'm on I like to have them easily accessible
I've got my messages my email which clearly I need to check that
Safari and my camera handle the next page. We have well. It says it's weather, but this is basically I need to change that
Actually, let's change that too
I'm gonna rename it to
stuff
This is basically all of the Apple stuff that I didn't really wanna necessarily, delete
But I don't really ever look at weather news stocks reminders iTunes Store iBooks home health kits wallet
photos FaceTime podcast compass find iPhone find friends tips a voice memo con
I can probably delete the tips the files app keynote iMovie watch. Oh, there's a watch update
I better get on that calculator pages music and TV
No, I do use a lot of these apps, but a lot of times when I'm looking for something
I just kind of swipe down and search for it so if I'm looking for pages
I don't really want to have it on my home screen
but I can find it easily by going into the folder or searching coinbase if you guys are a bit coin or aetherium or
virtual currency who
Purchasers owners, that's probably my favorite cube
This looks like a very fun game, but it's more a game of life. It's a period tracker. Sorry guys
Ladies you might want to check it out next we have Netflix their facebook Messenger
I clearly don't really use that very often because I could messages uber venmo
Sonos Dropbox the Apple Store Phillips hue which I love that's what I use to control my lights DJ
I go for that's what I use to fly my drone the activity tracker for my Apple watch and my phone
PayPal Spotify clips, I love the new clips act like you can push yourself and
It's kind of struggling because it uses depth to sense to remove the background and since I'm pretty close to this wall actually it's doing
Pretty good job. Let's see what else we've got metropolis. We've got this riverfront. This is my favorite
It's the Millennium Falcon so you can like look around and see stuff. That's around you. Oh a mega destroyer
What we look at this oh my god. What else is there? Ah?
sketchbook
8-bit
Teegarden these are really cool. New clips update is pretty great
I just wished that they would make it so that you can film vertical instead of making everything square because that really messes up when
I'm gonna save things to Instagram and like I can't put this in my story. It's a square. What are you thinking tumblr?
Saucy if guys don't know. What saucy is you guys may not be old enough, but it is an alcohol delivery service, so yeah
It's kind of like post mates, but for alcohol and last, but not least I have my games folder
I haven't really downloaded many games with teaser basically my go choose
I never made a video a long time ago making this cake from cookie Jam
But I'm currently working on something else very fun also from that game, so spoiler alert Jedi challenges
I did in a box scene with my friend Alex if you want to watch that video
I'll put a link in the description and an annotation somewhere here. It's kind of like a really insane, AR game
Where you can be a Jedi and you just use your phone you put it into the headset you have a lightsaber and man
It's just the best next I have goat simulator, which I just started playing I kind of want to do some gameplay of it
So I stopped playing so that I can sort of go through and you guys can see my actual genuine
Excitement and surprise from playing it because I opened it up. I was like what is this?
This is the best thing that I've ever seen in my entire life
I also have best fiends and best fiends forever because obviously
Another game that I'm obsessed with this is the destiny to companion app so if you guys play
Destiny at all that's something that you can use to alert your clan that you're gonna be going and getting ready for the raid
I still haven't raided yet
I just really need to take like a week off from real life and just sit and play destiny
Prestige and call of duty and finish Mario Odyssey. I think that'll probably be what I do during Thanksgiving and Christmas
So maybe then I can catch up on games well. I guess that's it
Let me know if you guys think that there's any other apps that I'm missing I did have a few AR apps there was it
Was that Dragon app it's like this little dragon friend, but I didn't download it on my new phone yet
There's a bunch of other AR apps that I do want to check out
I know I keep talking about wanting to try AR a if you have any other recommendations
Of ones that you guys like or some things that you've been playing that you think that I would also enjoy
feel free to leave those in the comments below and let me know if there's any other apps that you think that I'm missing I
Feel like there's so many apps that I can just get lost in the App Store
Downloading and buying things so if you'd like to help guide my purchases or free games
Let me know in the comments below and let me know what your favorite app is is there an app that is your favorite of?
All time whether it's an iPhone or an Android feel like probably the camera and messages app if everything else went away
I could survive with just those two things well. Thank you guys for watching
I will see you in my next video if you haven't already don't forget to subscribe so you'll see the next one be sure to
Turn the alerts on because I feel like that's the only way that people see videos now
That's a little bell. So you can click that on my channel and on all of your other favorite creators. Channels as well
Okay, I'm gonna go see you later